at a health clinic in the city of
putrajaya
malaysia's prime minister kicks off his
country's coronavirus vaccine campaign
the southeast asian nation plans to
vaccinate 80 percent of its population
of 32 million
by next year in neighboring indonesia at
one of the world's largest mosques
thousands of religious leaders are being
vaccinated this week in jakarta
using the vaccine developed by chinese
pharmaceuticals manufacturer
synovac the drive is part of the push to
encourage more indonesians to accept the
vaccine
we have a target of 17 million public
workers and religious leaders and 21
million elderly people
hopefully the second phase will be
finished by the end of june
indonesia is the worst affected country
in southeast asia
with more than 35 000 confirmed deaths
thailand will start vaccinating priority
groups including health workers this
week
using the same synovic vaccine the
country has received
200 000 doses more will arrive next
month
i thank china for sending us the first
batch of vaccines this month
the vaccines will keep arriving as
planned the philippines is yet to start
its vaccine rollout
and its labor department has sparked
anger for suggesting
it was open to allowing more nurses to
work in foreign countries
in exchange for vaccines from europe
when we first read
and heard about it simply we are
saddened and we we were hurt
as if we are like an object naped
with the vaccine vietnam has been
praised as one of the world's best
performers in handling the virus
and now it's received its first shipment
of vaccines
it will be hoping that will continue
when it starts rolling them out
next month jessica washington al jazeera
jakarta